starting at 9 p.m
[Music]
this is breaking news on 8 news now
and we start right now at 6 with that
breaking news police on the scene of a
deadly crash in the southern part of the
valley this is at bermuda and windmill
metro saying a motorcyclist involved in
this collision
has died the crash is causing some
traffic delays in that area 8 news that
will keep you posted on air
and inside our free app also happening
right now the investigation
into that enormous explosion rocking the
city of nashville
merry christmas everybody thanks for
joining us here at six i'm david charns
and i'm bianca holman officials say they
found human remains
in the area as elise preston shows us
investigators believe
this was deliberate
[Applause]
officials vow to bring those responsible
for this morning's explosion in the
heart of downtown nashville
to justice this morning's attack on our
community was intended to create chaos
and fear
in this season of peace and hope we're
not going to rest until those
responsible for this outrageous and
cowardly attack
are brought to justice the explosion
unleashed
giant flames and a cloud of black smoke
leaving a path of
charred debris shattered glass and
ruptured water lines
as officers swarmed to the scene police
said this
was not an accident we do believe that
the explosion was an intentional act
shortly before the blast police had
received reports of shots fired
as officer responded they encountered an
rv
that had a recording saying that a
potential bomb would detonate
within 15 minutes officers upon hearing
that
decided to evacuate the buildings nearby
minutes later the rv exploded knocking
an officer to the ground
the nashville fbi is now heading the
investigation
and says it has investigative leads but
also
asked the public for tips this is our
city too
we live here we work here and we're
putting everything we have
into finding who was responsible for
what's happened here today
nashville police tweeted this photo of
the rv as it arrived in the early
morning hours and asked the public for
information
the downtown streets were mostly
deserted on christmas morning which kept
injuries to a minimum we've made three
transports to area hospitals
none of those transports at this point
are critical the blast damaged at least
41 businesses and displaced an unknown
number of downtown residents
the mayor declared a state of emergency
for the area surrounding the explosion
a curfew is now in effect for the area
through sunday afternoon
elise preston cbs news new york
and back here at home catholic charities
of southern nevada offered a christmas
meal
to nearly a thousand men and women in
the community as kate houston reports
the organization says
the need this year is unlike any other
a steady stream of people filled the
outdoor pavilion at catholic charities
to celebrate christmas
and receive a hot meal today staff is
serving the homeless and those on the
brink of homelessness
their plates were filled with prime rib
vegetables and cake
catholic charities says this may be the
first nice meal they've had all year
give the guys something to look forward
to you know
there is hope at the end of the line in
the revolt you know
not over until until it's over due to
the pandemic
deacon tom roberts says this year has
been unique and challenging
while the need in the community has
always been there he says
it feels different i've met lots of
folks in the last
60 days and really throughout the
pandemic that have said
i never expected to be here and
we say you know what it's okay that's
why we're here is to help you
so that eventually you can not come back
here people like keith zorros who's been
homeless for a few months
i pray every night for that you know for
for a new beginning
for a new beginning because the pandemic
has
has ceased to make my life whole zoros
tells me despite the challenges he's
facing
he's grateful for what he has there are
people that are
better that are worse off than we are
i am blessed i'm a blessed human being
uh to have food in my plate you know to
have food in my plate
a full belly when i go to sleep and a
place to
to rest my head this is the 55th year
catholic charities has served a
christmas meal to the community
while there were no volunteers this year
staff was on hand to make sure everyone
followed health and safety guidelines
kate houston 8 news now catholic
charities developed a
special holiday menu for today's event
the meal
offered was free of charge for everyone
that showed up
all right let's check in with sally
jaramillo for your christmas forecast
and selling not as many clouds as we had
for christmas eve
but uh certainly much brighter we saw
today
and still chilly that's right we saw
that sunshine the good news is
that we remained with those normal
temperatures for today the high
should be 56 57 that's the normal where
we should be this time of year really
so still not as cold satellite radio
will show you some clouds still filling
in through for tonight mostly clear
conditions
expected really no sign of any alerts
or watches for tonight dry weather is
still lingering through and santa waving
hello so merry christmas to you guys
hopefully you enjoy from this
great weather really it was a perfect
day to go out there and enjoy from the
golfing course there you can see
the high 57 outside right now 51 44 for
you henderson and 52 for you north las
vegas
feliz navidad to all of you guys tonight
expect temperatures to drop into the
cooler
40s and eventually cooler 30s for
tomorrow we bring you more pleasant
weather 59 degrees around noon
increasing to 62 degrees and coming up
my full forecast
we have changes to talk about not for
tomorrow but by sunday we can talk more
about the chances for rain
and mountain snow back to you bianca all
right thanks aly
christmas is here and several las vegas
spent their day up at mount
charleston to enjoy the snow and spend
some time with the family
8 news now reporter madison kimbrough
spent the day up at the lodge and spoke
with several locals excited about the
holiday
and the new year to come i know it's
been a rough
2020 and the good news is it's almost
over while the snow was light that
didn't stop people from driving up to
kyle canyon for
the holiday and enjoying the brisk air
many people walking around with their
dogs
masks on taking pictures and admiring
the views
the mount charleston lodge quickly
reached full capacity as they had
breakfast with santa and mrs claus
and then transitioned into lunch and
dinner we are booked
at 25 it's not that hard for us to book
out normally
we do a four course dinner all the
traditional like grandma's house turkey
stuffing mashed potatoes sweet potatoes
pumpkin pie apple pie
and of course our house made ellis allen
eggnog a lot of people were disappointed
that they weren't able to dine in
but took advantage of the mild weather
to do some outdoor exploring
look at the weather out here there's a
bit of snow up here the restaurant is
unfortunately booked but that's okay
we didn't think ahead to make a
reservation so we're not going to be
able to go in unfortunately but
we'll still get to have our christmas
spirit right here on mount charleston
i think we're going to go for a little
hike right now because it's so beautiful
down the road a bit from the lodge
people were seen enjoying the snow
tubing and sledding clark county tweeted
out an advisory
asking locals not to sled due to the
lack of snow
but that didn't stop people traffic
picked up around 1 pm but no major
congestion
the lodge will be open until 7 pm
tonight merry
christmas and happy new year in mount
charleston madison kimbrough 8 news now
this christmas millions of americans are
facing a financial crisis with federal
unemployment benefits set to run out
tomorrow
right now the coveted relief bill is in
florida where president trump is
spending his christmas
so that he could sign that bill but it's
unclear if he will
remember just earlier this week he said
he may not sign it unless lawmakers
increase stimulus payments from 600
to 2 000 dollars believe it or not
democrats agree with the president
at least to the extent that we need to
sign this bill now
congress returning monday for a rare
late december session
after republicans blocked democrats
effort to push through that payment
increase
and david without that sign bill the
state's employment department says
hundreds of nevadans will lose out on
money dieter officials say they were
fully prepared to implement the relief
bill but now their hands are tied
the department says it's now virtually
impossible to avoid a gap in benefits
for nevadans
anyone receiving benefits from nevada
can still file
weekly claims those applying for pua
program will eventually get caught up
on the payments after the delay
the unemployment insurance website will
be offline tomorrow starting at
a.m to midnight for a system update
while the site is down
users will not be able to file claims or
access
resource materials maintenance will not
impact the pool website
he's the international award-winning
magician with several prestigious
best of las vegas awards including best
magic show here in vegas
he'll be part of our new year's eve show
now just seven days away
and as kirsten joyce shows us tonight
he's found a way to wow
millions of people all during the
pandemic this is a
very special study over hand you can
touch it
like this touch it go ahead
xavier mortimer's love for magic started
as a child in the north of
france he brought that fascination to
las vegas combining magic
theater and the arts to tell stories
seven years ago i started with cirque du
soleil
and then alex my producer saul
me and sergey soren said you should open
your show in las vegas
that was scary but now not so scary huh
no we've been working hard and after six
months
to a year the show started to really
settle
and we start to get our audience and and
have people come in every day
and that's that's the beauty of it you
start something you
you go for it because you don't know
what's gonna happen
after a four year run the pandemic
happened xavier's show a magical dream
of bally's placed on holt
so he improvised taking his illusions to
social media
i started to publish those little videos
on tick tock
and instagram and a friend of mine
called me and said you should do longer
videos you should do longer formats
you see the dots when you shake the bag
within months he became the most
followed magician on social media on the
las vegas strip
with the amazing ali sparks as bell by
his side
how many followers do you have now i i
haven't checked in a while but
unless i checked was around 8 million
and that's crazy because i started with
zero basically
i think it's so amazing to lift people
up because everyone is just
you know so down with everything that's
going on so it's really important to
remind them that
there are still moments to laugh and
have fun
and enjoy yourself you look stupid
until business returns to normal on the
las vegas strip xavier and his director
in the process of upgrading their show
to include some of his best online
illusions i'm
humbled and it's it's it's great it's
it's a great experience
express check out he can't wait to
perform once again
live on it like stage
shut up do it again wow
i can't wait to watch i'm an awning to
follow him right now on my social media
but all of course be sure to join us
live here on new year's eve as we cover
celebrations across the country
your favorites brian loftis and kirsten
joyce host our show
starting just before nine on new year's
eve all the way past midnight
eight news now will be live from stadium
swim inside
downtown's new circa resort we've got
performances from zoe bowie the eli
young band and strip headliners
like tape face our team will be socially
distant
screened and tested for covet 19 and we
hope you can spend a safe new years with
us
and during our show we're raising money
we need your help to do that to help
food banks across the country
with the super bowl of caring our goal
is to hit
1 million meals and i think we can do it
with your help
any money that you donate stays right
here in las vegas
david looking forward to that all right
coming up right here on the valley's
news leader betting on the raiders
we take a look at how the unknown of
quarterback derek carr's
injury will impact the odds
plus some weather continues for your
saturday before the next incoming system
kicks in sunday what it's looking to
bring behind it that's straight ahead in
your most accurate forecast keep it here
yes enough said call ed
all right welcome back there's only two
weeks left in the regular season and the
raiders need a win tomorrow
tomorrow night against the dolphins ron
fatrell joins us now with the latest
so now there are only two weeks left in
the nfl's regular season and this is the
time of year the time of season if you
will
when teams and sportsbooks are thinking
about the playoffs
and what do you know two playoff teams
the rams and the steelers both heavy
favorites in their games
lost to heavy underdogs last weekend the
old cliche
any team on any given sunday but
it is unusual for two uh big underdogs
like that to win straight up in the same
week so
uh last week uh if you threw a hundred
dollar parley moneyline parley on those
two teams your hundred dollars would
have got you back uh
eight thousand dollars and then you have
the raiders who are right around three
point underdogs
at home against miami this weekend the
number probably change if
carr is a going to play he's
questionable right now we opened the
game at
miami two and a half it's gone up to
three so if carr comes in
that game may go back down to two and a
half but
right now apparently everybody thinks
it's going to be mariota so the raiders
and the dolphins saturday night with
playoff hopes
hanging in the balance here at allegiant
stadium with the raiders i'm ron futrell
reporting eight sports now
and we'll have more sports in just a
minute we'll go into the movies on
christmas is a real tradition for so
many of us
and even during the pandemic some were
able to keep that ritual going
wonder woman 1984 premiering today in
theaters
also on hbo max this is the first movie
on the water brothers roster to be
released simultaneously both in theaters
and online it all matter to me it's all
the same but i love the smell of popcorn
so
come out here to movie theater i agree
with that warner brothers will release
17 movies next year both
online and in theaters and if you're
worried about going to the movies during
the pandemic
many theaters are actually offering
private showings
for small groups so bianca i have not
seen any of the
wonder woman franchise unfortunately but
i'm curious what's your favorite
christmas movie on this christmas day
um my favorite christmas movie i have
two so i like the grinch the cartoon
version
okay and then i also like the preacher's
wife with
denzel washington and whitney houston
yeah i
uh i'll uh yours what's yours well i'll
fully admit that today
before coming into work today i was
sitting on my couch
watching love actually sobbing to myself
you had tissue nearby i know i was just
blah blah blah it's so touching
so uh such a great movie any wonderful
yeah so let's you know head over to
sally everybody's probably they've
opened up the gifts
they've been outside and today was
beautiful sally so exciting